Taylor Swift might be the smartest pop
star of her entire generation reports
are that she dodged a major Bullet by
refusing a promotion from FTX the
bankrupt crypto trading firm now you
might recall these class action lawsuits
against Shaquille O'Neal Tom Brady Larry
David and a whole bunch of financial
YouTubers now we've covered these
lawsuits on the channel before basically
the lawsuits themselves are legally
extremely dubious and it's unlikely that
the promoters could have done any extra
due diligence on account of the you know
fraud that FTX was perpetrating Taylor
Swift actually came close to a reported
100 million dollar sponsorship but the
plaintiff's attorney who's suing all
these celebrities said that quote the
one person I found that did that due
diligence was Taylor Swift in our
Discovery Taylor Swift actually asked
them can you tell me that these are not
unregistered Securities so apparently
Taylor Swift had this thing where she
was getting older but she actually was
getting wiser and if you need a great
lawyer for anything from crypto to car
accidents let my firm the eagle team
take care of it any legal issue anywhere
in the US we can help link in the
comments